[Música]
o pessoal de 20 e hoje vão ensinar como
fazer um barquinho elétrica utilizando
um pedaço de ter ouvido uma garrafa 1
tornou bateria e mais algumas coisas que
vocês vão ver ao longo do tutorial
então vamos lá para fazer cabine do
barco precisa de uma garrafa mais ou
menos retangular tinha parte da rolha e
tem cortar algo mais ou menos deste
gênero rock não vou dar um beijo de uma
vez que as garrafas vão ser diferente de
pessoa para pessoa e portanto acompanhe
esta aparência
se vocês quiserem podem fazer este duas
cordas dobre para cima o que sobrou pode
usar um alicate para ficar mais fácil
esse processo e depois terem que o
retângulo e fica assim depois possível
com uma lancha depois fazer cabine do
barco cidadão pudesse servir para fazer
base
este serviço é bastante fácil encontrar
no mundo vem numa caixa de um produto
que vocês cumpram não tiverem podem
comprar aqui bastante barato mesmo sem
importar com estas medidas
aproximadamente o importante é que a
gordura seja igual a largura da garrafa
ou seja tem caminho que vocês fizeram
tentes ea espessura tem que ser igual ou
superior e três centímetros numa ida
base faça um circo com o diâmetro da
rolha da garrafa
isso é só acrescentar uma coisa pra dar
a direção do barco ou seja vai poder ir
para direita ou então para a esquerda
consoante vocês vão mudar a agulha vocês
vão ver isso mais para frente como
enrosca da garrafa no orifício que
fizeram mas tenha cuidado sacola quem
estiver demasiado que empunhou cola na
partida rosca espera em que ela fica um
pouco mais fria e depois cole faça o
mesmo para a partida acabe
[Música]
faça um orifício tampa da garrafa para
isso podem usar um x-ato vão mudando até
que fique mais somente com espírito para
movimentar o barco precisar de um touro
e usar um todo um dvd player
mas se vocês não tiverem podem sempre
usar um brinquedo antigo e tenho vários
dvds players porque foi uma loja de
informática e os deram os velhos que as
latinhas ele o plástico do cantor
lançado um chupa-chupa que dizer não vou
anunciar só do candinho do chupa chupa
vocês podem comer flux ado colo e
canudinho e vejam só como quem cola para
fora então tem que tirar tudo para não
dar problemas depois da rolha que
fizeram a abertura pedrinho e tem colar
desta maneira começar por uma base para
eles podem aproveitar a garrafa era uma
faixa e essa faixa tem que ser de
largura da filha que vocês vão usar eu
vou usar o que uma de 9 volte é eo
console com o resto é porque não vamos
tentar fazer conexões até que o encaixe
direto no motor marca em que esta para o
braille é para trás depois viu o tamanho
certo em cada autor
e eu teria isso vai variar pra vocês se
você usar um tom maior tem que fazer
esta faixa maior também
veja aqui como funciona em inglês sem
tradutor sem fio sem nada observa
encaixar o autor na base em fazer este
corte uma inclinado da amargura dessa é
chique amaury dumbo torku bateria
e claro como é o vento foi de vocês têm
que verificar se capucci cobertas ocular
que estamos a fazer é realista o barco
para isso e vou usar uma velinha para
nos ajudar a fazer o circo mas se vocês
não tiverem vergonha como esta é só
fazer um circo com mais ou menos um
diâmetro de três centímetros que tem que
fazer as embarcações com sonar lógio e
vão cortando mas nunca podem chegar
àquela parte do maior caí no chão lhe
uns milímetros mas nunca cheguei aqui o
pontinho que eu marquei lá no maiorca aí
você tem que marcar e ajudar bastante
bush foi moldando desta maneira
se vocês forem crianças peçam a jo do
mundo porque fogo ok e agora fazer esta
parte que vai dar a direção do bairro
varjão eu achei a rolha e essa patologia
preto é a direcção daquela faixa que
está ali no lado direito a cair aquela
faixa vai encaixar pelo orifício fiz
agora e ela vai ficar ali por baixo do
braço e consoante eu vou dando a agulha
vai dar a direção ao bairro não cobra em
caixa é livre o retângulo
vou terminar tem que fazer um orifício
michaelis união cola dos dois lados para
ficar mais forte e pleno ao pãozinho do
chupa chupa espero terminar mas para
terminar mesmo mesmo vocês têm pintar o
barco com esta quinta
vejam só que o bonito está a ficar
parece que os barcos piratas da somália
e depois de uma guerra muito bonito
a escola é uma reação em troféu 20 e 30
é que prontos e não sabia então foi
apanhado de surpresa é mais a minha
sorte foi que eu tenha feito o teste
antes aqui no lava louças e vocês
conseguem ver que o motor tem muita
força mesmo é e provavelmente ainda bem
também no lago no sítio com mais água
só espero que tenham gostado de ver
algumas estão já os comentários e tchau